it's been six years since frozen came
out in theaters and we've been patiently
waiting for the sequel to follow suit
please I can't live like this anymore so
we're happy to announce that it's
finally happening
frozen to is set to come out on November
22nd 2019 and although this seems far
away we now have a teaser trailer to
help tide us over here's everything you
missed in the new frozen 2 trailer
what is also training for disease new
frozen 2 trailer starts off with a bang
we're immediately greeted by Elsa who's
seen training next to a rocky shore
we've seen also run through a frozen
lake before but this time around she's
trying to make it across an ocean which
looks mighty difficult from where we're
standing huge wave swallowed the ice
princess as she tries to freeze them
over but the ocean is all-powerful
making it hard to beat if there's one
thing this segment shows us it's that
Elsa is training for something really
important so perhaps there's a huge
threat coming Arundale zwey also battles
the waves as lightning and thunder roar
through the sky this intense scene sets
the pace for the rest of the trailer
which only gets more hectic as it goes
on what's floating around in the castle
as a huge wave comes crashing down over
Elsa's head
Anna wakes up with a start she runs to
her balcony and stares in disbelief at
the strange blue shapes floating around
the castle these shapes seem to be a
part of Elsa's famous snowflake
formations and they also appear to glow
in the same light as Elsa's ice powers
these two first clips take place at
night leading us to believe that they're
happening at the same time could it be
that Elsa is broadcasting these shapes
as a warning signal if so she might
seriously be in danger these fragmented
snowflakes could foreshadow that Elsa's
powers are getting weaker as an enemy
approaches Erindale where's Chris stop
running to the third thing we see in the
frozen 2 teaser is an angry-looking
Christoph riding through the forest on
spends back but it looks like Anna's
boyfriend is super determined to reach
his destination he's got a wild pack of
reindeers following him through the
woods but what could they possibly want
from Christoph the only explanation we
can think of is a forest fire and
since hints of one hour later showcased
we just might be on the right track
Kristoff loves reindeers so he might be
leading them to safety for old times
sake
why is Danna leaping from over rocks by
now we all know that Anna is one of the
bravest isn't Erik ters ever in fact if
she was a witch she'd definitely be a
Gryffindor and from the looks of it she
probably wishes she was a witch
after all leaping from rock to rock
would be a lot easier if she had a magic
broomstick unfortunately for Anna she's
got to do things the old-fashioned way
in this scene we see what appears to be
hints of the ocean so it could be that
Anna saw her sisters distress signal and
came looking for her on the rocky shores
this would definitely make sense
considering the setting but we'll have
to wait to find out
the mysterious fuchsia fire Olaf might
love the summer season but he's prone to
melting which isn't ideal luckily for
him
Elsa's got everything it takes to keep
him intact we come face-to-face with a
mysterious fuchsia fire and it makes us
more than a little nervous for Olaf
after all Elsa seems super busy so he
might start melting without her
realizing it the pink fire is circling
Elsa and the snowman so we're led to
believe that they're being attacked but
who does this liquid firepower belong to
we're not so sure but actors Evan Rachel
Wood and sterling K Brown have been
added to the casting list so perhaps one
of them is wielding this deadly attack
talk about intense you've probably
noticed that the frozen to trailer
starts off with some pretty intense
music in fact this track intensifies as
the trailer progresses making viewers
feel nervous for their favorite
characters it seems as though Elsa Anna
Kristoff and Olaf are going up against
an all-powerful foe and from the looks
of it this enemy has something to do
with the fall season Robert Lopez and
Kristen anderson-lopez are reprising
their roles as the film songwriters so
we can expect some pretty amazing
musical numbers to alleviate our spirits
for now it looks like frozen twos
background music isn't going to be as
joyous as the original film soundtrack
new characters we know for certain that
frozen 2 will make way for a few new
characters however their names have been
stricken from the casting list to
protect the sequels mystery there's a
quick shot of a young girl standing in a
red forest we see something or someone
rather burrowing through the ground
before being spit out of a pile of
leaves at first glance it's easy to
mistake these characters for anna and
kristoff but upon closer inspection it's
obvious the man is too thin to be
Kristoff and that the girls hair is too
red to be Anna's could these be the
villains we're all curious about if so
they're doing a great job at keeping a
low profile because well they seem more
like victims than antagonists fall is
here Elsa might be the ice queen but
she's one to enjoy all of the seasons so
why then does she seem baffled by falls
arrival if there's one color that keeps
popping up it's the color red so we're
led to believe that whoever the
antagonist is will have fire wielding
powers and since the mysterious female
character is a redhead we can only
imagine that she's up to no good
but what's her problem with Elsa and
Anna and why has she set her sights on
arendale although we're powers might be
strong fire is no match for ice one of
the last scenes we see in the trailer is
the gang looking over a mountaintop the
entire forest is colored with red leaves
but hints of snowy mountains can be seen
in the distance could this before
shadowing the battle that's to come we
think so swordplay the last thing we see
before the trailer goes black is Anna
swinging a sword our way but now we all
know that anna is good with her fists
after all she did send Hans flying into
the ice cold water but we've never seen
her wield a sword before all we know is
that Anna Elsa and Kristoff are walking
through a spooky forest and something is
hot on their trail this confusing piece
of information isn't the easiest to
decipher so we're left with nothing to
go on
but we'd love your help so let us know
what you think Anna is swinging at in
the comments below
that's a rat don't forget to subscribe
to the things and get this video up big
thumbs up thanks for watching and see
you next time
[Music]